hi I'm Oliver Grasso from transients is
consulting based in Berlin our mission
is to help companies transform their
business and we use simulations to help
companies manage the complexity of
transformation and in my presentation
today I will teach our to build great
stories around simulations using
Mathematica okay good morning everyone
my name is Oliver I'm a management
consultant and we use Mathematica to
both simulation models management models
and today I'd like to show you our
approach to do that I guess most of you
know why simulation what is important
essentially you know what we tell our
customers is as you know in complex
situations it's just too risky to
experiment with your business it's too
risky to change your business model
without thinking about it in advance and
so one good approach to dealing with
that complexity is to build simulation
models okay so instead of experimenting
in a real word build a simulation model
experiment with new designs with new
policies in the world of business
simulations come up with different
approaches and then realize design using
prototypes as a guidance now that's the
simple story but unfortunately in
reality even if you build a great
simulation model you know between having
great ideas and actually putting them
into practice there's a big big gap okay
and so what we will soon realize is that
in order to get people to take action
you need to tell a good story okay so in
order for your simulation models to have
an effect on your business you need
stakeholders to take action and we find
you know trying to tell a good story
rounding your simulation model is a good
approach to do that so the question is
which tools you use to do that okay I
now traditionally and the way we
approach that is we have a sort of
iterative process so first of all and
this is this a problem problem solving
process so we try to understand the
challenge we build a prototype we call
it prototype and we prototype the
business builder simulation model design
design new policies test the policies
and eventually
come up with some future scenarios and
then the storytelling starts okay we try
to build a story around that now
traditional tools you know which tools
the most companies used to tell stories
they use PowerPoint right they build
powerpoint presentations and if they're
sophisticated they might be using
something like you know more powerful
like Adobe's Creative Suite and I think
they're great tools and I use them a lot
myself okay but the problem is they're
not very good and especially for this
iteration iterative part at the end you
know but you know when you're building
simulation models I'm sure most of
you've done that before you build a
model you build your presentation and
then someone comes up with a new idea
new data you have to change the model
you have to change every graph in the
presentation which takes ages okay just
takes a long time and so these
traditional tools even though they're
great for visualization they're not so
good when it comes for handling data
graphs and algorithms for what I call in
an iterative rental engineering I
working both on the simulation model and
the presentation at the same time and
they're not very good at providing an
environment for for experimentation and
I think half the fun of having a good
simulation is playing with the inner
experimenting with even for top
management yeah it's a useful thing to
do okay so now we know and I obviously
we will know what a good solution do
that is we can use Mathematica right
this mathematic is a great tool for
building stories for building
interactive presentations but now the
question is how do you approach that
okay now I don't know you know one of
the tools we use to build business
simulations is I think it's a system
dynamics modeling tool our system
dynamics is a actually now fairly old
approach to building simulation models
and a good thing about it is it uses a
visual representation and we find even
you know we can even speak to people who
are not I don't have a sophisticated
mathematical background using this
visual representation and a good thing
about these tools are they they firstly
they use the fairly intuitive notation
I'll get into that in a minute okay you
may know it already assistant and I make
some the tool here is I think but there
are a number of tools on the market one
can use so first of all they use an
intuitive graphical notation secondly
they show you the overall structure of
the systems they don't get lost of
equations okay so even though to ask
mathematician
and I'm a mathematician myself by
training in all these things we could
just do that within equations and I
actually like equations okay so I'd
actually quite be quite happy to do that
but a lot of people don't like equations
most people like mathematics know what
happens if they share mathematics to
people who don't like equations okay so
that's my visual visualization is
sometimes good secondly you can show the
the overall structure and you know
businesses are complex and we sometimes
have simulations with three or four
hundred equations and that gets to be
quite quite a lot of information need to
handle okay these tools are good at
doing that and thirdly you can hide away
the details so you can focus on the
stuff that is important in other instant
okay so sorry so what I'm trying to say
is well mathematic is great but it's
also good to have visual modeling
environments and I think Wolfram noses
that's why you get a system modular
we've also looked at system model of a
building system dynamics equation models
and you can do that but I'm not so happy
with the with the current implementation
so that's why we're at the moment still
working with I think and we find i think
is a very easy-to-use tool and it can
also be used by people who are not very
sophisticated when it comes to dealing
with with technical details okay so how
do we combine the two words now what
we've done we've used the power
essentially of Mathematica to create a
little pass or a little converter and
what we do is we take the I think tool
we build a model and actually I think
uses a let's call it a sido standard
they're trying to standardize the
language they're using it's called X
miles an X my xml based format and we've
built a little converter that converts
the x my model into a dot m file model
or time i've put it in the graph and we
also have a little sister dynamics
package which gives us utility functions
and then we can run it in Mathematica
and a good thing about it is because you
also may know from your experience that
one of the problems with building
simulation models and having these tools
is deployment how do I get people in the
company to use my model if the only way
I can run it is by running it in a tool
that costs a lot of money that
not be easily accessible and so on and
often now we management consultant so it
takes us let's say two or three months
perhaps at most a bullet simulation
model many large companies it takes some
six months to get a tool deployed okay
so by that time we've left the company
unless you're looking for the tool okay
so that's no way to go so first the
mathematic is a fairly good way to go
but obviously we can also use things
like Wolfram player but what we also do
is we actually deployed amusing using a
web browser and our converter can
actually have the multiple formats so we
can convert it to Mathematica which is
great for the prototyping process for
the iterative process and if you want to
polish it for final use we can deploy it
to the web okay so that's the technology
but obviously we here today to look at
the creek concrete example so let's do
that and this is the simple model I'm
going to demonstrate I'm obviously you
know this is a very simple model much
more simple than the model we you know
the models we build for our clients but
but the good thing about it it's
something that affects all of us and so
you know I want to also give you an
interesting model to think about so this
is a model that explains how we get
things done okay so essentially we've
got open tasks we want to get them
completed and turn them into clothes
tasks okay and how quickly we do that
depends on our completion rate okay in
the completion rate will depend on our
productivity and the productivity as
many of you may know depends on schedule
pressure okay I think most people may
have that experience at least in my case
that's that's the case you have a
deadline and it's approaching well let's
save its four weeks away the first three
weeks you do nothing and worry about it
and then you get started right i get the
presentation finished just on time okay
that's what schedule pressure does to us
yeah and the worst thing that can happen
is that someone extends your deadline
was what happens then you go out and
party and say yay deadlines gone away
and you wait again for the other two
weeks and then you get the pressure back
again okay I think all of us have
experienced that that's a simple model
to show this okay so the key idea behind
the model is that the schedule pressure
isn't constant but sorry that the my
productivity isn't constant with
schedule pressure is low then my
productivity is fairly low and then they
put a schedule pressure gets higher and
higher and eventually my my productivity
goes up and it goes up beyond the one
because I end up doing overtime yeah I'm
not taking any breaks all the stuff we
all know okay so that's our simple model
now how do what does this look like in
Mathematica well first of all okay we
have this pastor that converts it into
into da temp file we used to initially
we built the parser using mathematic
itself which is fine I mean why we use a
different technology simply because we
wanted to use a parser generator because
we're not interested in building
sophisticated passes and they're quite a
few cool parts and generators out in the
market and so we use one of those so
first of all I import the import my
assistant dynamics package and I can
import in the model in this case it's a
temp file and we've created in our
package created a few abstract data
types in this case the simulation has
the data type simulation okay
appropriately good so the first thing we
want to do we don't take a look at our
simulation so this is what it looks at
this gives gives them a little is a bit
of statistics so it tells me something
about what kind of stocks I have that
system dynamics peak we discern between
stocks and flows shows me their my flows
my completion rate what we saw before
hand on the on the on the diagram and it
shows me the converters or which
essentially these are the equations okay
in which constants are half so that
excuse me a quick overview of the mortal
and before I go on I'll just quickly
show you what the model looks like in
the modeling environment so I can get
this across here
okay so this is I think to this is what
the model looks like in the modeling
environment and if I wanted to I could
look at the equations in the modeling
environment and that's what they look
like in the modeling environment okay
and so I can I can play around with them
but the model in the modeling wife and
what we've done we've imported it in its
entirety into mathematica stand I we
independent of the tool okay let's get
the magical back good okay so now we've
got the the modeling in Mathematica so
the first thing i can do i can look at
one of the one of the equations and one
on one of the equations is open tasks
okay so i can say look give me the
equation and in this case this is the
representation of the model with in
Mathematica system dynamics is very
simple from the mathematical point of
view it's different equations so to
calculate the number of open tasks at
time T I need to know the number of open
tasks at time t minus my delta time and
then I dish add in the the number of
tasks that coming through the completion
rate okay so mathematically it's really
really simple okay and so there's that's
why in Mathematica we didn't have to do
any clever tricks to actually evaluate
the simulation was mathematically can do
that anyway right that's what the tools
for okay so now i can say let's work out
the open tasks time five and it gives me
Becca value I can look at the open task
that time after 20 days and I've got 80
tasked open and so on okay if we go back
to the model settings which is important
for h1 for the simulation I'm assuming
that we have hundred open tasks and each
task takes me a day to complete and my
deadline is hundred days away so if I
work steadily I should be finished after
hundred days okay and then we can
experiment a little what make a few
changes to the deadline to see what
happens okay now one of the problems
with these tools with these visual
modeling tools is handling different
scenarios and so when our main objective
was to have to put in some scenario
management capability okay and obviously
the easiest way to do that and what is
the scenario a scenario essentially a
collection of
of parameters of settings for the model
constants okay and so what we did is and
that's a natural thing to do
mathematically use the options
mathematica options format okay so we
have an evaluating function which lets
me override the equations and then I can
set the set the options using using the
standard mathematical tools okay then we
can create a scenario manager which
again is a an abstract data type called
scenario manager and then i can define
it two scenarios so let's define a
scenario we've got hundred days 100
tasks but let's put the deadline at 80
task since he had see what happens okay
and then we can have a scenario with
hundred days hundreds heart on a
deadline of 100 and then let's look at
what happens if we put the deadline up
to 120 okay and then we can evaluate the
scenarios and then we get a graph
showing us the different results ok and
now given the simulation i showed you
before hand without going into the
details of the model it's pretty obvious
what's going to happen if i have hundred
days I get finished bang on time if my
deadlines is a bit short I still managed
to get almost finish on time as my
productivity goes up ok but if I have
120 days you know normally I should we
finish off the hundred days but I've
only got a hundred task but it takes
more than 20 days ok and that's just
given the setting we saw before hunt and
I think you probably will agree you know
that in this case the simulation fits
pretty well with our experience and have
someone gives you five weeks to do a
presentation you're gonna take five
weeks ok no one gets finished a week
sooner ok and let's ditch the word
that's what this model shows ok now
obviously that's digital what have we
done up to now we've defined a few
scenarios and we've showed some graphs
in Mathematica it's nice but we could
have done that using PowerPoint as well
it would have been a hassle if someone
had said look I want to know what
happened with the deadline hundred and
forty we would have to change the graphs
and everything but it would have worked
now let's look at making interactive
scenarios and that's really simple as
well so we just create a scenario I've
called it's in the interactive scenario
but it's dish another scenario which
I've added to my scenario manager and
using the Burton the built-in features
of mathematica i can start manipulating
it so in this case this it and we've got
something called a graphical input
device that's part of our system
dynamics package so now I've got the the
schedule pressure we saw beforehand but
in this case now I can start
manipulating it ok this is using
standard mathematical features okay but
I can start playing around and we can
say look you know some people they never
get productive okay that's probably the
productivity curve of some large
corporations oops my mouse isn't hitting
it well this changed the curve a little
so I can play around with it okay now
this is you know looks neat initially
but if you've got a hundred points to do
that it's a bit of a hassle so what
we've had added is sort of something we
called paste points so you can paste the
oops use interfaces disappeared you can
paste the points let's say from XL
mathematically now has a new data set so
we could use the data set feature so we
just try to use the features of
Mathematica to make it as easy as
possible okay but you can see how easy
it is to create one of these devices
okay so it's all a rake so when you're
building the interactive presentation it
goes away it's a very fast process ok
now let's now we can see how this will
affect our deadline okay so we can go to
the next page on this case I've got a I
can play around with my deadline and I
can see you know whatever I do even if i
put the deadline down you know my
productivity is so low it's to take me a
long time to do it okay and so that lets
me play around with with my model okay
so there was the lesson what's the
lesson from from the model I think this
is an important lesson I don't leave
you've heard of Parkinson's Law before
you know but it essentially says the
effort needed to do an amount of work
always expands to fill the time
available to do it and I think something
that's def worth knowing and to be
honest if I manage management
perspective it means you better have
closed deadlines because people then
they use the time anyway you give them
and from the from a personal perspective
it means that obviously the time you
lose
initially he never defined again and so
in the end you end up working very very
hard if you don't manage to get the
productivity up as as soon as possible
okay and this please me to the end of my
presentation so what's the conclusion
number one is to really make business
simulations effective you need to be
able to tell a story that motivates
people to take action I think that's the
key the key takeaway and what we've
learned even for business applications
mathematic is a wonderful storytelling
tool that's very very flexible very very
fast and in my opinion even though
there's a little learning curve
initially the learning company isn't as
big as one imagines and we can handle
fairly complex models using a very
limited set of of Mathematica features
nevertheless you want to use visual
modeling environments because they're
useful for maintaining large and complex
models and so one easy thing to do is to
try and get the best of both worlds and
in our case we import the model into
mathematica and run it there okay thank
you